قبل اقل من عام بدات روسيا عمليتها
العسكريه بدخول اقليم جمباز من الشرق فما
هي ابرز محطات العمليه الروسيه شرقي
اوكرانيا القوات الروسيه وصلت التقدم في
مارس واقتربت من السيطره على اول مدينه
اوكرانيه كبيره شمال شرقي البلاد وهي كمان
نشاهد هنا حركات انتصار وصف بالاستراتيجيه
تحقق في شهر مايو بالسيطره على ماريوبل
المطله على بحر از اوف بعد صمود نحو جندي
اوكرانيه داخل مصنع ازاكستان للصلب لحوالي
الشهر بعد السيطره الروسيه على ماريو بيل
ومدن عده في اقليم جمباز بقيت على الجانب
الاخر في الشرق مدينه
في الثامن والعشرين من مايو تمكنت القوات
المواليه لروسيا من السيطره على مدينه
ليمان مركز مهم السكك الحديديه في منطقه
دونياس كما هو معروف في يونيو الماضي اعلن
حاكم لوغانسك سيطرت القوات الروسيه على
مدينه سيبردونياسك الاستراتيجيه في الثالث
من يوليو وبعد احكام السيطره على دنيا
اعلنت القوات الروسيه السيطره على منطقه
فيما تبقى امامها منطقه دونياس لاحكام
قبضتها على اقليم دومباز باكمله انذاك كما
نذكر شهر سبتمبر شهد مشاهدينا تقدما
اوكرانيا شرقي مع السعاده بلدات رئيسيه
بينها ايسيوم في ديسمبر وبدايه العام
الجديد تتركز الجهود الروسيه على مدينتي
سيفرياس وباخمه المجاورهتين
وسوليدار المجاوره هي الطريقه الاقرب
لتحقيق هذه الاهداف